ومع امتداد القتال الى منطقه الجنينه غربي
اقليم دارفور يستحضر السودانيون تلك
الرقاعات من بلادهم التي لطالما كانت
مسرحا لصراعات بين الجماعات المسلحه
والحكومه يقع اقليم مادار فورف في الجزء
الغربي من السودان وتقدر مساحته بخمس
مساحه البلاد يقارب عدد سكان الاقليم تسعه
ملايين ونصف المليون شخص ويسكن دارفور عدد
كبير من القبائل ابرزها الفور والمساليت
والمحاميد ورزيقات وترجع تسميه الاقليم
الى قبيله الفور تعني موطن الفور وتحد
اقليم دارفور ثلاث دول من الشمال الغربي
ليبيا ومن الغرب تشاد ومن الجنوب الغربي
افريقيا الوسطى وينقسم اقليم دارفور
اداريا الى خمس ولايات شمال دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه الفاشر وجنوب دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه نيالا وغرب دارف ور
وعاصمتها مدينه جنينه وشرق دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه الضعين ووسط دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه
يمتاز اقليم دارفور بثروه حيوانيه كبيره
قوامها الابل والغنم والبقر وكثيرا ما عرف
الاقليم بصراعات بين الرعاه والمزارعين
تغذيها الانتماءات القبليه نشطت في دارفور
جماعات مسلحه ابرزها حركه العدل والمساواه
بزعامه جبريل ابراهيم وتكونت من مسلحين
معظمهم من غير العرب جيش تحرير السودان
بزعامه مني اركو من ناوي هذه الجماعه
تشكلت نتيجه لانقسام قبلي بجيش تحرير
السودان وارتبطت بقتال فصائل الجنجويد
المسلحه المتهمه بارتكاب فضائع في دارفور
جيش تحرير السودان فصيل عبد الواحد نور
ينظر اليها على انه القوه القتاليه المهمه
الوحيده المتبقيه داخل دارفور حيث يعتمد
قائده على دعم قبيله الفرن